after two weeks of being confined to
their hotel rooms members of a world
health organization research team are
beginning their investigation in wuhan
their mission to find out as much as
possible about how the coronavirus
outbreak began
before leaving quarantine who team
member marion koopman spoke to al
jazeera about the immense job ahead
in the whole process is try and get as
good a picture as possible of the
initial
findings starting here in wuhan
talking to all the colleagues that have
done the primary work that have done
additional studies
trying to you know aggregate everything
there is to learn
from this initial phase of the pandemic
but more than one year
after the beginning of the outbreak
experts say the team's findings will be
limited and discovering the pandemic's
exact origin
will be difficult it is very unlikely
that we're going to find a smoking gun
which i'm sure is going to be a cause
for further politicization of the virus
by
different international uh in groups and
states
um i think realistically what we're
looking at
with this mission is a narrowing down
of the very wide set of options the team
could have
those options include exploring the
theory the virus was first transmitted
from a wild animal
such as a bat and that it first
circulated in wuhan's huanan seafood
market
who researchers are also planning a
visit here wuhan's
institute of virology where for years
chinese scientists have studied
dangerous pathogens
including coronaviruses former u.s
president donald trump
alleged that covert 19 leaked from this
lab
the chinese government has dismissed the
claim and has in turn raised questions
about the work conducted in u.s military
lab
fort detrick in maryland which was shut
down in july 2019
information about the early days of the
curve at 19 outbreak has been tightly
controlled
but beijing insists it's being
transparent
we have no intention to misguide public
judgment
or the who's work coopers feels positive
about their investigation
and has this message for the public be
patient
this will take a long time and
because that's how science works it
really will take a long time don't
expect us to step out and say okay so
now we can tell you exactly what
happened because that will not be the
case
both the who and china have been
criticized for not doing enough to
prevent the virus from spreading
but team members say their goal is not
to point blame
but to find evidence to help fight the
pandemic
katrina you al jazeera wuhan